hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The Last
of Us ok so apparently didn't save us
putting this ladder back this should've
moved me okay I'm not gonna get angry at
this game because I just got over being
angry at this game it's a great game and
there's lots of great things it just
decided to be a little bit dumb along
with me I'm at fault too just a little
bit for what happened before hang on I
need to go oh it didn't even pick up the
arrows from before I gotta make sure
that I got everything hang on
no don't melee the dead body yeah okay
we're gonna go under here real quick
just see if there's something that I
might need or is there something there
that I might need which one is the
secret area I don't really know which
I'm gonna go this way first though
alright let's go let's go Ellie let's go
wait a minute oh I see okay this is just
a way back alright nevermind I'm dumb
excuse my dumb this and excuse my
inability to figure out crafting sooner
but I mean I'm trying as hard as I can
please have mercy yeah you act like I
started I shot a baby on a dog in the
face oh wait oh wait okay now let's see
ooh we have more arrows here and an
actual bow cool yeah sweet can I give
that to Ellie I know we just leave this
kind of stuff to me yeah you shoot me in
the back I don't trust you little girl
no way no how
I'm the man here I'm gonna make the
decisions yeah that's right because
apparently we have devolved into a
sexist world why I mean she has a 14
year old so there is a certain reasoning
behind giving her deadly weapons okay
how do I get across here oh now I'm
gonna be stuck again alright there's
gotta be some here worth looking at if
not this door and I've got to be able to
get across here somehow which means that
I need a plank of wood
and I can I can get the plank of wood
that I just used to cross right can't I
le do some team work here you go girl
come on help me out no no don't go back
up I was pushing down okay go down there
we go yes son of a gun
alright so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna get this use this yes and I'm
gonna pass it up ally you're so strong
why don't you pick that up prove your
worth
Oh Ellie you're not gonna do anything oh
oh I'm sorry oh are you were you over
there looking at stuff don't worry I'll
get it
geez thanks so much Ellie I hope you
don't strain your back looking over that
ledge wishing for someone to fix it for
you oh jeez okay yeah here it is oh oh
here it is oh you finally decided to
look at me good for you grumble grumble
grumble grumble grumble grumble grow I'm
an angry old man don't listen to me
alright carrying it whoa whoa whoa back
up back up I got I got let's uh let's
give this baby well shoot this guy in
the face see ya are hang on it's like
the Huntsman in a fortress douche yes
and most likely I can recover that arrow
right which is why the bow and arrow is
very good bill ain't exactly the most
dangerous individuals so when we get
there you let me do the talking you
understand mmm-hmm I understand gotta be
clear on this you you don't take too
kindly to strangers it was a good guy
you just definitely need some time
do you even be paranoid about a
fourteen-year-old girl then seems kinda
iffy okay cutscene Oh No no cutscene oh
I thought that was a cutscene never mind
stay underneath it okay just keep your
head low and we'll be fine yeah we
already talked about that before let's
see what we got over here more bottles
yeah this is Shiv door I want to see
what we can find
find my body when I die from the heart
don't worry I got this
you're too young for a heart attack all
right what do we got in there can't see
a bloody thing don't hear anything
there was a bunch of noises being made
earlier like just a few seconds ago nope
don't hear anything
hello hello what's going on what's going
on something don't feel right here okay
I got i got more full items which means
i need to craft some stuff like the
health kits i need to create a bunch of
health kits so I can get more rags this
is what you guys were yelling at me
before but I'm trying my best
I really am okay so anyway I got the med
kits I need to make another yes okay got
that now I can pick up more items here
get those I'll crash down on the ground
perfectly normal oh I'm sorry were you
busy beatboxing over there where I'm
taking care of all the baddies god damn
it where the hell of you come from you
scared the piss out of me give me that
give me that back no kidding
kid well we're here let's search the
place yeah let's search the place great
idea man where'd it come from
okay Rachel Oh move le Alli Alli gosh
dang it Alli man okay anyway Rachel
soldiers are going door-to-door for some
people under the buses I hear yelling a
couple buildings down time's running out
I tried calling waiting I don't know
what to do anymore but I can't wait
anymore and throwing more stuff in a
couple suitcases I'll be waiting for you
in the quarantine zone come find me I'll
see you soon Etra
okra okra I've no idea do you think they
ever found each other
probably not
no I'd like to think they did think they
did then doesn't make it right but if it
makes you feel better go right ahead
all right I think that's everything for
in here got some goodies plenty of
goodies made some stuff I'm getting
smarter about playing right getting
smarter see these are another jumper
coming out of me was there anything over
here nope okay let's get the hell out of
here a ride no trespassers but bill is
me
don't you remember your buddy Joel how
we go you should go moonshining down the
Appalachian Mountains
you lived we all went up in that man
don't you remember don't you remember me
bill don't you remember your old buddy
Joe okay anyway enough reminiscing I
don't know how we're gonna get back a
bug right on my nose okay don't know how
I'm gonna get past this so let's throw
some that it let's throw this bottle I
Oh si si si shoosh yeah yeah alright
pick up a repel it's lots of bullets
hang on let me get that one out how are
we supposed to get by that one oh you
still beat boxing while there's work to
do oh don't worry I'll go back and get
another bottle you just stay there Ellie
manners to Jim Burton to me it's a good
thing I like you wait a minute no I
don't that's right
okay let's try this again I'm sure bill
has noticed the explosions of his traps
but maybe he just thinks that's normal
zombies shut this guy sure can throw
well Rick lock me some bricks better
than bottles I imagine you could
probably use a brick dose to eat a
zombie to death we don't see why you
wouldn't
hey morning lots of ammo there's more
ammo than I've ever got in my life well
none something Oh
ow everything's all upside-down stupid
traps yeah stupid bill well they're that
fridge that looks like that's a
counterweight okay go push it you're so
strong Ellie and it'll bring me down oh
why can't I flex my amazing ab muscles
in I'm gonna fall or night I'm gonna I'm
gonna fall down oh no oh oh no oh oh oh
crap
I'm not gonna be able to I can barely
aim normally oh crap I see you over
there
oh god golly I'm in trouble over trouble
upside down fighting come on stop biting
my nose you douche
Oh head shot got you okay reload crap oh
crap oh crap oh crap
head shot nicely done me I would sell
five me but I'm kind of hanging in a
situation here I'm just hanging out
no no no God no no God why I'm so bad
I'm snow bad uh god damn it oh come on
that wasn't even ready Oh still
complaining about the last unfortunate
death that I suffered hey that wasn't a
headshot there is some sort of a misis
that a no way maybe there's okay all
right no no no come on just fall over
and die there we go
reload for the last clicker don't fail
this time whoa whoa where'd you come
from there we go reload
I think that's damn how many of them are
there this is why they loaded me up with
ammo isn't it Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me I'm so
bad at console shooters by the keyboard
these guys would all be dead but I don't
so this is what I'm left with Jesus
Christ how much okay there we go
finally I use like all of my bullets
jeez Ellie thanks so much for all your
help you're so great I am so
appreciative of the efforts that you've
committed any day now Ellie any day what
what am i catching what did I just catch
mo what would you finally useful for
something Ellie
dammit all right I got a protector Ellie
now so I really can't miss or I'm gonna
miss again and again and again and again
and again and again come on damn it
oh come on what am i doing reloading one
bullet at a time here oh you gotta be
joking me you've got to be joking me
just reload a full gun oh I swear I
swear damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn
oh no that's a clicker there we go we
got a headshot in oh come on it's not
dead another headshot blew his head
apart
any day now Ellie any day now
there we go Thank You Ellie ready to
fight fighting as fast as I can smash
this button Billy bill you son of a
[ __ ]
I'm freaking pissed off at you let me
tell you that this guy I'm screwed I'm
running can't fight three of them let's
go let's go let's go
at least bill is a good shot nah me
though buy me bro 1v1 snipers let's go
they gotta go in come on let's do let's
let's go let's go
okay thank you God dang it
I'm so mad how angry I'm so angry you
know no you don't oh no oh no oh what
have that a headshot for you
close enough not close enough any day
now
this is why I don't like the revolver
cuz it's so it's so involved to reload
it sorry I think I just shot you bill
alright
hunting ammo that up following I only
got three bullets left them so boned yes
me first Ellie you you you're yearning
no danger here it's me they want
I'm too important to die you just let me
let me through first
man what summoned them all that's not
fair I was all ball that's what that was
anything sprout god damn it I'm clean I
see so much as you done am I do you come
into my house you set off on my traps
you're damn near break my shooting arm
who the [ __ ] is this Punk and what's she
doing here I am none of your goddamn
business and we're here because you all
Jolson favors it starts by taking these
off kayo Joel some favors is some kind
of joke I'll cut to the chase I need a
car well it is a joke Joel so screw you
buddy
well if I had one that works which I
sure as hell don't
who makes you think I just give it to
you huh
yes you're Joel go ahead take my car
take all my food too while you're at it
what it looks of it you could lose some
of that food listen to me you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you think I need you to
shut up alright whatever favors you
think I owe you ain't worth that much
actually bill they are yeah bill no
matter cuz I don't have a car that works
but there is one in this town parts
there are parts in this time meaning
that you could fix one up
alright I'm gonna do this there's some
gear I'm gonna need about time bill in
town now you help me go gather it and
maybe I can put something together that
runs but after this I owe you nothing
that's fine a couple days from now we'll
probably be dead anyway goody goody
gumdrops
follow me Oh goddamn town's booby trap
they stay right on my ass yeah yeah yeah
now I'm starting to like Ellie whatever
supplies you may want or need I suggest
you grab them you got it buddy
I'm all over this I needed to use my
melee weapon a bit more than that last
battle but hopefully I won't be thrown
into just a horrid mob of enemies any
time soon wait what what did I just do
hey you know how to play this yeah
pretty badly
yeah well now's not the time
Bobby what let it go let it go you let
it go with ain't no way ain't worth no
trouble how do I get behind the bar cuz
I see some things behind the bar Qi
Ellie we're good we're not good we are
not good SHIVs last one hit longer
let's select of you see I need to get
sharpening durability of Christians read
so I'm gonna blade
alright I know how to get better SHIVs
yay hooray for me don't know why shows
we'd have one use anyway unless if
clickers have had acid blood or
something that would cause them to
denote aliy nullify anything that I put
in them okie dokie
stay with me can't believe you agreed to
this [ __ ]
what you should have done but just left
them back there we can hear you we what
kind of trouble are you in yeah you're
gonna help ass what are you delivering
yeah you know what you were saying
something where we go and bill we just
you up that but it doesn't have as much
durability it feels a metal bat maybe
yeah I'm all about that hey I don't know
if there's any supplies that are missing
I'm kind of checking the rooms here but
there's not much inside my question
about Tess yeah I thought the two of you
were inseparable don't bring up Tess
she's busy oh I guess I wouldn't want to
tell him either none of his business
anyway leo
ooh
birdie there's that church that I was
looking at before that's what we thought
bill was why don't you fix one of these
cars oh my god you're a genius
I mean the whole time what am i doing I
thought about fixing one of these cars
okay don't be a dick their tires are
rotted and the batteries are dead are
you done gaining begin to think what the
inside of the engine block looked like
only ones making new car batteries are
the military damn it
uh-oh what are we doing you take care of
it I'm just gonna I'm just gonna you
know stay back here and think about what
you're doing there he looks looks
important looks bad
come here a mortgage oh no oh come on
how is that even remotely fair this is
bull you guys said that I needed to be
calm collected and quiet what I need to
do is I need to shoot the [ __ ] out of
everything that I see and I'm gonna
start with a freaking Molotov cocktail
right over there take that suck that
down
there got you that time okay there we go
now they're burning good there we go
that's what I'm talking about
asked what I'm talking about see bill
you see bill do you see bill yeah
sometimes I talk to myself too like
every day for about three hours and up
we go all right whatever you say don't
know why though such an abundance of
zombies around here for this guy's been
living here for awhile I don't
understand how they're still zombies
because he seems like the type that
would clear it out on a regular basis
being as paranoid as he is but that's
just me don't understand it whatever
place the whole more history more bad oh
I missed something out there yeah man oh
it's just a brick okay I'm fine all
right where we go and Bill up this way
Oh am i leading oh excuse me I don't
have a key I wonder how smart the
infected we're in the cellar got it
yep I wonder where Joel's brother is
like seriously here we are you don't
touch anything
yeah new girl close the door birdie
let's gear up
uh-huh what I need a gun no you don't
Joel I can handle myself
no just stage you got a steel gun that's
what I do fine just wait around for you
two to get me killed
well this goes on record as the worst
[ __ ] job you've ever taken uh-huh
heads up there Oh in the hell is tests
okay with a suicide mission actually her
idea really when the brats not as smart
as I thought she was Oh [ __ ] don't be
like that man take that kid back to
where you found her I can't just take
her back and send her packing let her
find her own way that's bad but let me
tell you a story once upon a time I had
somebody that I cared about partner
somebody I had to look after and in this
world that sort of shit's good for one
thing getting you killed get you killed
there we go
knew it so you know what it did why
isn't the [ __ ] up I realize it's gotta
be just me mm-hmm
it ain't like that it's [ __ ] it's
just like that Hey what I said you we
walked down the steps what'd I say
just fixing your stupid pile don't touch
yet you keep babysitting long enough and
eventually it's gonna blow up in yo face
can we please just get off
here you know for being a loner builds a
talkative guy shotgun yes love shotgun
perfect weapon for zombie apocalypse I
don't even need to aim with the shotgun
so it kind of negates my poor skill but
I only got six bullets though we go any
further I got something to show you
alright what have you say man please
don't beat your penis I really don't
don't see that Oh God I really hope it's
not your penis nail bomb you gotta be
really careful this thing blows it
shreds anybody standing there by okay
I've seen your handiwork cool how do I
carry that it looks very uncomfortable
to carry okay lava bombs explode when an
enemy gets close use offensively or
defensively it can be throwing using l1
or more strategically placed with r1
undetonated bombs can always be
retrieved sounds good to me so we got
shotguns and bombs the hell are we doing
with them well every three weeks this
military Caravan rides through town I
assume they're out looking for supplies
I mean you'd be amazed at the [ __ ] that
they overlook anyway
few months back they were rolling
through and they get overrun with this
horde of infected they're all over the
truck it plows right in the side of the
high school still sitting there with a
battery in it cool like that batter and
we put it in another car bingo I'll
stick with the chocolate candy but it
seemed too dangerous with all the
infected on that part of town cool make
sure my work sounds good to me
let's do this let's do this I do I need
another Molotov the answer is yes always
okay new [ __ ] alright okay we're good to
go I'm good to go
Gaston go alright let's get out of here
oh workbench didn't even know this was
here let me upgrade um I don't know if I
picked up any other ammo for this gun I
really don't so I mean I don't know what
to say about that but there's one thing
that I know that I'm gonna like in the
future but I don't have
those part things the tools so I guess
that's a moot point anyway either I
haven't found one or I've overlooked it
so let's go got to go or maybe there's
one right over here
gasps - there's one right there
all right cool tools level one yeah
there's one thing that I know I'm gonna
love which is the bow and arrow because
it's silent
it's retrievable ammo and generally it's
just really good so I'm gonna make sure
that I have upgrade that as I know whose
spot
are I reload speeds range draw speed Oh
decisions decisions the things that I
got update upgrade find a silenced
pistol I'd be very very very happy but I
know that I'm gonna need this so let's
get the range up cuz I want to use this
from a distance anyway okay I'm no
Legolas I'm not gonna be shooting from
dead on so let's go gasp to go gasp to
go come here come here
thank you thank you okay where are we
going bill bill where'd you go bill bill
bill where yet bill oh there you are
bill okay let's go bill Joel needs a car
a brand-new car yeah
Joel you are keeping an eye on her right
yep I got Huck what would it matter bill
the old recluse you ain't got anything
worth taking anyway in here Wow nice
place you got here
you got anything to confess this would
be the place to do it um I don't know
stole a pack of gum once felt real bad
about it time to sack up
oh boy we're going into a cemetery
really bill we're going into a freaking
cemetery this this another como every
zombie movie this is never a good thing
zombie games school movies okay okay
what is with that controller thing what
is going on with that why does it tell
me to do that I don't know come on you
don't need to be looking at that this
gate it's all new territory me alright
well I hear some keep quiet
hang on I know how to take this guy out
don't know how keep a bow and arrow in
my backpack but okay I'm just gonna nail
this sucka in the face or not cuz I
don't trust myself to aim
scheisse just stay right oh crap
how in the world am I supposed to be
able to get that okay
all right everybody just calm down holy
crap
damn it huh being problematic here okay
just stay still stay still lady don't
twitch anywheres you're not posted okay
where's the other one
okay there's one down there now in the
immediate area and then this yeah next
one over there did you see that shot
you see I shot
oh crap did I break that don't move
don't move don't move don't move lady
Oh what the hell I hope those aren't
breaking I hope those all didn't break I
bet they all broke you've got to be
joking me I just broke everything
screw it we're going with the shotgun
cuz apparently I suck too much damn it
it was such a good shot
screw it hey buddy how's it going there
what's that what's that you're ugly
oh woe to many of you always in forever
always in forever always in forever I
will die too those damn clickers the
sons of [ __ ] at least at least now I
won't have the embarrassment of losing
all of my arrows and maybe I can get
closer and try it again because that
would probably be much smarter now I'd
probably be filming tomorrow then doing
whatever whoa
hey buddy that's going friend just stay
right damn it stop moving around so much
you stupid son of a [ __ ] do I even have
to give a headshot on these I think you
only get to recover if you actually hit
him like even a body shot would be fine
I think okay I just got to be silent in
this place because if I don't just leave
it just a little bit
no-o-o-o-o-o stay stay stay goddamn it
I'm gonna just hit him in the body
Seward or I'm not or I'm not or I'm not
gonna do anything
stay don't [ __ ] move
last one just get it in there we go okay
oh no I always did every hair oh you can
only recover it if you get a head shot
I'm I I don't know I don't know what's
wrong with me I'm just a giant pile of
crap that's all I am
there's too many down here what if I
throw down a bomb if I do that yeah let
me try this because if I throw this over
there when they walk over it it'll blow
up but then they won't know where it
came from right
what was that you should go towards that
whoa yeah that was why didn't you kill
that other one it shoulda whatever it's
only two now I can probably shotgun him
come here come closer
look closer go closer reload you didn't
hear a thing lady what's that
what oh what's that oh there we go
secure that there seriously I mean I
guess I could have I probably could have
stuck through all that but yeah I was
probably dumb that I did all that in the
first place but I don't care I
successfully navigated this place right
and no one will doubt my expertise now
okay so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna just sneak past these guys
where is or where is my destination find
the destination first and then go there
I think I need to go either through that
door or up there what is that over there
some more supplements
okay just be very quiet
and we'll be fine Jesus bill could you
be louder could you be louder bill and
could you actually help me out here this
this doesn't look good it's not where I
was supposed to go bill man seriously
you are loud and not very coordinated oh
my god oh my god oh my god okay we're
fine I might be able to weigh again I
think I can just come here you [ __ ] I'm
gonna grab you and then [ __ ] yeah all
right
there we go and then I'm just gonna
sneak by this one oh I can't believe it
I can't believe it
Hey what was that over there am I
playing this professionally now I mind
actually doing good cuz apparently bill
and Ellie can come thundering down and
no one gives a [ __ ] did I do one little
thing over there it's a bomb
what you should all run as fast you can
over that way oh me
shut up Ellie jeez shut your face okay
come on we got to go we got to go gotta
go gotta go oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god mm-hmm okay we're fine
define we're fine there's just a lot of
clickers really close there's an opening
I'm gonna ship this one whoa what the
hell bill
Jesus you walked right by one that
doesn't seem possible but you did it
bill you frickin rhinoceros I gotta grab
this one and then ship it that's bill
Wow
oh my god did you see that bill is
trying to get me killed here bill is
being a giant douche and trying to get
me killed I swear oh god bill hold up I
got a key for that bill yeah really you
suggest we move quietly you're freaking
God okay just gonna distract him hey
what was that way up there wait there's
something here more bottles I need one
mm-hmm what's that way over there okay
let's go kidding about this place where
you
oh crap there's so many of them all
that's a clicker there's so many of them
you guys didn't hear [ __ ] oh oh oh oh oh
no oh no oh I know this bad this bad I
don't have any more throwables oh god oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no shotgun
where's the clicker got a good way from
the clicker get away from the Cougar
grab grab grab on the way
run run run run run run run run run run
run run grab another brick run run run
grab grab grab grab grab grab grab grab
grab arrows arrows arrows thank you
thank you thank you
is that a runner is that are they behind
me okay whoa where are we going now I
can't believe I got out of that hmm
okay where are we going Phil can you
give me some directions here bill I do
not know where we're going I was kind of
in the middle of running very quickly
and grabbing whatever I can and I may
have missed something somewhere did we
even go the right way oh here we go
lawn mower thanks Bill man you are so
subtle this way
oh it's tired on the other side what
about going through here what the doggie
door uh-huh yeah go on Ellie I trust you
completely maybe you should have given
her a gun okay bill
there's more of those clicker things
inside the house oh crap of course there
are so many damn clickers seen this yet
you stay down oh crap
I think I can get by them but well this
is gonna be close this is nerve-wracking
this seriously is really nerve-wracking
just don't make any sudden movements
everybody be very quiet we're inside
there's another one over there I can
shift that one if it's the only one okay
seems to be the only one I'm just gonna
shove it and get the hell out or maybe I
can hit it with an arrow if it doesn't
mind me swapping out right behind it it
seems to be pretty stationary which
means that I might be able to hit it in
the head just like that easy peasy
okay can't recover the arrow so it's
just random I guess whenever you can
actually recover an arrow just everybody
be very calm don't make any sudden moves
bill I'm looking at you if you come
stomping in here I will be very upset
that's more like it bill thank you very
much bill okay now are they any supplies
in there that I could use yes definitely
uh I'm not gonna get it I'm just gonna
ship this one because or I'm just gonna
take that and get out of here oh there's
some tape over there and I'm not
important enough not important enough
cuz I'd waste a shiv to get it and I
don't even want to bother to get it
on the RV and over should be clear okay
sounds good yeah a tree house yay it's
like my childhoods back all over again
sorry for not commenting much on that
last part boo was kind of intense and I
was very focused on not dying again see
when I focus I can actually do stuff no
although I got some idea who might have
come through here this house let's get
inside
alrighty then you got it bill any
supplies supplies supplies wise wait
there was some there oh no that was the
door over there okay
if this open bottle of booze scissors
okay looking good looking good I think I
can craft another ship if I'm not
mistaken no I need that tape damn it
whatever it's not worth it there's
something over here anyway yeah supplies
oh I got a ship sweet badass lots of
arrows I like it man with this full of
arrows how can you be full take as many
as possible man okay whatever I should
have just killed that other zombie to
get the tape with the arrows just try it
anyone to tell you there's that truck
sticking out of the school right there
come on seems kind of you know hard to
get to maybe we'll want to take another
road maybe just maybe maybe just a
little bit maybe maybe maybe alright
fine I'm getting really involved in the
game by the way I'm just kind of letting
it all sink in and I'm really thoroughly
enjoying this game really try not to
make a sound foam-filled thumb thumb
thumb thumb thumb thumb thumb way to go
bill your freaking hypocrite is there an
actual day/night cycle or is it just all
scheduled group for Boston wait Boston
where are we are we in Massachusetts
okayhow where do we go
hearth hearth or okay where do I go
there's a barbed wire fence whoa whoa oh
crap no no Phil you couldn't tell me
you're gonna shoot it well alright then
I guess there's no clickers I'm fine
thanks for the assist bill you're
punching this that's not good headshot
oh crap
punch you down just get bones but I'll
help you build Wham okay Thank You Ellie
for noticing my incredible skills okay I
don't know who tripped that one but
they're not blind so they obviously
probably just looked at me and saw how
handsome I was and came a-runnin that's
probably what happened
nice giraffe he supplies nope okay we
kill them all we're good to go
didn't take too much damage we're fine
but I don't know where oh here okay
hello is anybody there right in between
him just what I wanted to do they're
coming out of nowhere I've got my
freaking bow and arrow out when I should
have some else head shot where are they
coming from I didn't even see a single
one and all sudden boom they're
everywhere and there's one of my left
why why did that happen why is that a
thing watch you before you can polish me
man oh crap
come on this isn't fair this isn't fair
this is not fair why are there so many
moles why are there so many can I climb
up on something thank you very much that
is much better
whatever that means okay oh hello
oh come on this is this isn't good this
isn't good I'm not doing well here it's
like ten bajillion of them how am I
supposed to be able to fight him up whoa
excuse me can you guys do something bill
could you like shoot yeah that'd be nice
can I climb up on this bus so I can get
a breather because I need to use a med
kit I'm not doing too hot excuse me lady
I know you seem angry but your anger
really isn't directed at me so you're
just angry at yourself really that
that's the real thing okay
I'm switching out for the shotgun
because screw this noise where is it
where is it
way to go you're almost as bad a shot as
I am bill thank you Bill about time see
what I don't understand easier than you
thought it'd be really how do we get
inside I'm gonna upgrade ooh what didn't
sway I don't know what that means shift
master Oh use a ship to save yourself
one grabbed by a clicker that would be
nice but um yeah I mean that's that's
fine I don't mind that okay let's just
heal up forget all this I'll save up for
the ship master so that hopefully
that'll save me a little bit of reload
time for a save game reload I mean okay
so don't know where the hell these
things are coming from it's all bull
it's all baloney
okay where are we going where we going
bill bill where are we going where
okie-dokie what have you say babe okay
jeez Ellie lose some weight gosh darn it
don't get killed up there you know it's
really not that high I don't see why I
wouldn't be able to just jump and climb
up that cuz I mean if you didn't jump up
and grab onto it then there's no reason
why you shouldn't be able to pull
yourself this is a fine mess we've
gotten ourselves into bill isn't it let
me guess they can get over that thing
just fine okey-dokey all right whoa get
up get up there wait get up there first
jump bout damn time Jesus that's a
clicker
oh I really don't like clickers I really
don't like it what where to where
anywhere but here
oh crap another running sequence at
least I won't have to do any shooting
that's what I suck at the sneak out the
back is that a clicker
that's a clicker isn't it screw you
clicker [ __ ] just oh crap reload
reload oh my god no no no no no no no
reload there we go nice teamwork and I
get V all this ammo that dropped cuz
thankfully some of these zombies have
the common courtesy of dropping ammo
which a lot of them do not okay got a
bottle plenty of ammo radio I've totally
forgotten what you said bill where were
we supposed to go Rick bill where were
we supposed to go science lab is this
where we're supposed to go
how about you go look over there I need
that melee weapon oh it's got spikes on
it okay I'm actually gonna pull out the
old hunting rifle see if I can't
actually score a head shot on that
clicker there we go not dead you're
joking right
you're freaking joking me that clickers
are coming that clicker is a-coming
gotta get out of here come on come on
come here come on
yeah that's what I thought okay clicker
dead clickers not dead she's sent us the
toughest clicker I've ever seen in my
life you're not getting me you're not
getting me there we go Jesus I shot that
clicker in the face with a hunting rifle
this is baloney that's all baloney
hunting rifle apparently sucks ass all
right whatever yeah can I get them all
with the Molotov down this hallway
about no no no no no no no
burn burn you [ __ ] thanks Ellie
you're actually helping good job okay
no one's dead yet thank you finally bill
all right did that still burning
probably would hurt me all right we're
doing pretty good we haven't died in a
while and that's that's something to say
from me so I hope you guys can cheer me
on in that regard
yeah one more thanks for helping meet
bill isn't gonna hold it for long good
is it a boss Tommy what what is that
ow what the loader take cover
whoa is that infecting me right now is
that what's happening right now oh damn
it
there we go how about we go out there is
that a good idea
no this bloated was just kind of hanging
around this pad you know just being what
loaders do I'm gonna switch out to the
shotgun no oh no you don't
oh yes it did it did it did that why do
I always have long gun out never the
right gun for this situation ow owie ow
that really hurt you son of a [ __ ] I
don't have anything to burn you with or
else I would just gonna take care of
these guys first shotgun I'm good yeah
there we go
they're gone taken care of where's the
big guy right behind me that's what it
sounds like what you doing there buddy
nice shot wow you almost got me on that
one
come on come on out where yeah where you
hi buddy Oh
looks like a charging
how do we kill this thing just shoot it
until it dies I would assume is the
general strategy
[Music]
oh crap you just do all the work bill
I'm gonna dance around like a lunatic
and then we'll meet up later so much
[Applause]
[Music]
okay's head is almost all the way gone I
would think that this thing would be
blind to I think I actually got a hit
there Thank You Ellie you're actually
being helpful thank you so much
nice job there buddy okay get out of
here I need to switch out to my other
pistol because apparently I need to use
all of my ammo okay
thankfully I actually have some bullets
in this gun
Oh gotcha [ __ ]
take that finally alright it's been
infected for a long time we call them
loaders yeah yeah I think we can but
before we do that this is a good enough
time to stop is anything so I'll give
you a boost in a second alright so
that's all the time I have for this part
so thank you all so much for watching
hope you're enjoying the hour-long parts
I know I am because I'm just playing the
game I'm having a lot of fun playing
this game so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]